The judge today ruling that
Dominion voting systems
cannot bring up the January
six insurrection during its upcoming
defamation trial against Fox.
But the judge is also blocking F
from bringing up certain evidenc
that the company
had hoped to present to the jury
and from making some
First Amendment argues
to defend the numerous lies
they presented to their viewers.
Jury selection begins Thursday.
CNN's Oliver
Darcy is following the case for
And Oliver,
what's the significance
of these rulings today?
Ahead of the start of this trial
Well, Jake, these
these rulings are pretty signifi
in that they will shape
some of the rules at the trial,
which is set to start on Monday.
The judge, as you said, ruled th
or that Dominion
cannot bring up
the January six attack on the U.
Capitol.
The judge saying that
this may be for another court
another time,
but it's not for this court at t
That said, Jake,
the judge
did rule in favor
for dominion on a number of issu
The judge ruling that they can b
financial information
that they found in Discovery
as it relates to Fox
or compensation, for instance.
They can bring that up
as economics are relevant.
And he also talks
about how Fox can not bring up
some of the broadcasts
they aired
in which they fact-check
some of Dominion's
or some of Trump's election lies
He says that's not relevant to t
at hand here
because you can't absolve yourse
he says, from defamation
by putting someone on
at a different time.
So some victories for Dominion.
Some for Fox.
Again, like you said, this
jury selection
starting on Thursday
and the trial will go on on Mond
with opening arguments
unless a settlement
can somehow be reached
between the two parties.
Meanwhile, these lies that Trump
and his minions,
including those who work at Fox,
told about Dominion,
they're still here
and still impacting how Republic
look at electronic voting.
Tell us about that.
Yeah, Jake, lives have consequen
and it's pretty clear at this po
that a significant portion
of the GOP base
has been influenced by these lie
And some of them are in charge o
you know, voting and
and coming up
with the systems in place
for people to vote.
And so for instance, over in
Shasta County, a county in Calif
they're no longer comfortable
with Dominion voting machines
because of some of these lies.
So these lies did have consequen
That's
why Dominion is taking Fox to co
And we'll see what happens
in the weeks ahead.
Oliver Darcy, thanks so much.
Let's bring in former
federal prosecutor and CNN legal
Ellie Hoenig.
Ellie,
we've already seen
so many of these damaging texts
and emails
from Fox executives and hosts in
in which they acknowledge
the nonsense
they were putting on their air
and putting guests on their air,
they knew to be false.
If you were a Fox attorney defen
how would you feel going
into jury selection
this week about your case?
I'd feel queasy, Jake.
I would not want to be in the po
of defending Fox here.
I think they're headed for a ful
journalistic and legal disaster.
It is very difficult
to successfully sue a media outl
for defamation in this country.
What you have to prove
is what we call
actual malice,
meaning the statements were fals
and the defendant made those sta
knowingly or with reckless
disregard of the truth.
Now, that's a very high bar,
but here we have
Fox's own texts in black and whi
where they call
the election
fraud claims,
and I quote nuts, insane B.S..
And so you contrast that
with the things that Fox said on
And I think Fox
is in a very difficult position
Now, the judge
granted partial summary judgment
to Dominion in this case.
What does that mean?
How significant is it?
Well, that's a big win for Domin
because the judge has now ruled
as a matter of law.
In fact,
these statements about election
fraud were false.
That's not even going to the jur
So the judge will tell the jury,
I instruct you jury
these statements were false.
Your only job is to decide
that actual malice question.
Did FOX know or were they reckle
And so with that ruling, Dominio
is really halfway
to where they need to get.
Are we going to hear,
do you think, from some of the
the high profile names in the ca
whether it's Rupert Murdoch
or Sean Hannity?
Absolutely.
Rupert Murdoch,
the judge ruled, has to testify.
Sean Hannity is on both sides.
Witness lists.
Maria Bartiromo
and others are very likely witne
And Jake,
when someone's a news anchor,
they're sort of
used to asking the questions
and dictating what the topics wi
Let me tell you,
the tables are going to be turne
when those folks are sitting
in the witness box.
It will not be up to them
when the questioning is over.
what the topic will be.
They're going to be
at the mercy of the judge
and the lawyers Bill
Barr, the former
attorney general
who's been pretty clear
about these lies being lies.
He wrote an op ed saying that
he did not think that
this would be
a good decision for journalism
writ large.
If Dominion wins,
I don't know if you read his cas
but you've heard the First Amend
arguments. What do you think of
I disagree.
I think they're that the First A
needs to be very broad.
It should be broad.
We in the media
take advantage of the First Amen
as we showed it's part of our sy
but it's not limitless.
And if as the allegation is here
any outlet or any person lies kn
that it is false,
then yes,
there can be civil consequences.
So I disagree with Attorney Gene
on that.